et bien bonsoir mesdames mesdemoiselles
loiselle messieurs je suis vraiment très
heureux ce soir vous
nous
oui comment qui êtes vous moi ce qui est
mon stick espagnol un moment à ne pas
rater pareille ou mais vous êtes très
joli vin chaud de rien mais non mais non
je m'en fous et dites-moi est-ce que je
peux vous poser une question
vous êtes un garçon et une fille - vous
êtes quelque chose non vous mystique
très maignan aller chanter quelque chose
reste encore bon
pardon pardon à ma main
c'est très bien à bientôt et
merci mille fois j'aurai besoin
maintenant de quelques personnes pour
m'aider et j'aimerais aller j'aimerais
beaucoup avoir michel drucker et enrico
macias nous adorons la prévu
et également également ce soir
j'aimerais avoir deux personnes du
public
elle qui ne s'y attend dé moi je vais
demander à l'est peut-être à ce monsieur
qui est là oui allez formidable
messieurs de nancy de paris par vidal
est en train de se coter une dame s'est
évidemment rouge
oui vous venez m'aider or il n'y a pas
de problème on encourage également
madame ou mademoiselle
donnez moi la main s'il vous plaît je
vous ai fait attendre une toute petite
seconde je suis désolé voilà très très
bien merci
c'est très facile je vous demande
simplement d'ouvrir et de fermer la
bouche sans parler uniquement ce aussi
regardé comme un poisson très bien alors
essayé avec vous monsieur aux avancées
un tout petit peu je vous remercie vous
êtes avec l'équipe de nancy
non oui objectif de nancy a très bien
supporté
alors lorsque j'appuie une fois sur
votre main vous ouvrez une fois la
bouche hockey lorsque j'appuie 2 vous
ouvrez deux fois un peu bon ça a l'air
de marcher très très bien vous avez
compris et c'est pas douloureux et non
non non non non non non voilà là et
quelle jolie voix vous êtes baryton on
va essayer
attention c'est à vous est ce que vous
êtes prêt au bon dieu qu'est-ce qui se
passe ces couacs avec vous êtes un petit
peu enrhumé haut que d'eau que d'eau que
d'eau
et cette fois vous avez perdu l'accent
rocailleux mandat mais ça va bien alors
écoutez vous avez vous repensé pour la
dernière chanson merci beaucoup au non
lieu non loin de lui est devenu un vieux
monsieur et madame très bien merci
alors regardez regardez le public ne me
regardez pas et auquel michel vous êtes
prêts aulas ça va très bien ah ouais
rien ça vous fait pas mal non plus 1 à
l'aller a réservé you speak english a
gagné ici ce soir nous avons une très
jolie femme
ouvrir un peu plus dans la bouche et
veulent pas fâcher un petit peu timide
quand même un première fois à la
télévision
oui c'est la première fois mais ça va
très bien ici ça va bravo alors il ya un
habitué
non je croyais que vous dormiez est ce
que je peux vous demander quelque chose
ouvrez un peu plus grand la bouche oh là
là elle est en colère
le dites moi est ce que vous êtes mariés
n'ont pas d'histoire elle avait entendu
ça vous intéresse elle est très jolie
voulait l'épouser
et vous qu'est ce que vous en pensez
vous voulez réfléchir alors en fait ça
avec une petite chanson musique s'il
vous plaît enfin vous restez ici
merci bien vous même ici je me mets ici
donnée - 7 7 mais monsieur voilà et
haricots cette main merci
agricole creditor louve no way diffusé
jeudi
la la
dis-moi l'air bien content en effet pas
content j'ai tout alors oui pourquoi pas
ce que j'ai entendu tout à l'heure car
et 200000 côté chien coty chaque était
abandonné tous les ans en vacances
ah oui et c'est vrai tu crois je crois
oui il ya conviennent penguin abandonné
eh bien je crois que cet été il y en
aura un seul toit oui tu as un vendeur
ni peut-être un lien
il ne renie mabanga écoute le chocolat
coûte cher onana l'année d'avant garde
et la garde et moi je te dis bon c'est
d'accord je te garde a dit vigneault à
je te fais un bisou
de toute façon si je cite il n'y avait
qu'à regarder j'aurais été chez tonton
du luxe chez tata darel relâcher mon
cousin germain
raymond lefebvre oui au total mois sur
saviola ce qu'on abandonne les petits
chiens vous donnant donnant on n'a qu'à
dormir alors sur yon recommencerai plus
non
parlez pas tous à la fois un cours comme
un simple bon d'accord alors écoutez si
vous regardez rôti chien chez vous à la
rentrée
je suis sûr qu'il vous auront gardé un
gros tas de crottin chocolat à écouteur
tu aimes alain chamfort à ouidah et bien
voici alain chamfort
bon sens mesdemoiselles et bonsoir
messieurs non à tout le monde en général
et pour quoi tu parle doucement coq a
dérayé plus fort mais quand ces
messieurs mais dis donc qu'est ce que tu
vas là non oui tu es malade
non je suis marqué car l'émission domino
taux supportables et guy des antilles
c'est ce que j'ai dit non il n'ya jamais
te dire je suis candidat aux élections
présidentielles
tu te présentes écoute le store
président français française et nestor
et si je suis élu une cocotte en
chocolat pour tout le monde tous les
vivants
écrit à la racine j'ai peint temps
tandis que soient fiers culture et non
spitaleri culture avortement
l'aviculture tiens j'en avais pour la
peña et gary et tu comprend un canard
enfin voici chercheurs vous êtes une
fille et coude mais tu crois tout le
monde va voter pour toi est ce que tu
connais quelqu'un qui va voter pour toi
ah oui c'est vrai quelqu'un qui va
vraiment voter pour toi
ah oui mais qui mois d'août en attendant
mon jeu je vais te mettre au lit quand
sera le premier cliché de nos
tu t'appelles tu t'appelles comment un
appui taille et comment tatelier tout ça
est ce que tu habites batailler avec toi
oui d'accord mais où est-ce que j'habite
moi comment tu sais pas je suis toujours
dans une caisse quand tu rentres à la
maison
dis moi ta taille et tu vas à l'école
pourquoi je suis
qu'est ce que tu fais alors toute la
journée rien rien du tout tu t'en met
pas la taille haie taillée
il ya quelque chose qui te fait plaisir
1 oui quoi que tu ne t'y chanter avec
tes questions à la cause
recevant l'as à ces mallettes à tailler
un petit bourg et là moi je me suis
gouré
oui ta niche et malin tatayous mais
c'est normal je suis ventriloque tu
connais pas je parle sans remuer les
lèvres
vingt six saynètes à tailler satan
bouche un coin hein comment nos moi
aussi un jeu temps sans renier les
lèvres oui mais moi je parle avec ta
voix et et moi je parle avec la tienne
et sans remuer les lèvres
ok ok cool non marionnettes alors
comment ça qu'est ce que tu veux faire
avec ça qu'on montre mais tu peux pas te
tailler minutes
bon bah il y en a une dans tabouret si
tu veux qu'est ce qu'il fout là dedans
c'est moi qu'il y ait misé avant le
spectacle
pourquoi parce que je savais bien que tu
allais m'en demander une et j'aime et en
simultané ya dix mois
oui mais voilà six mois que j'ai écrit
le sketch
qu'est-ce que celle instruit tous cac tu
veux savoir avant de le jouer
bon eh bien tu vas descendre de mon
genou
oui tu vas te mettre debout sur le
tabouret tu vas dire que tu as l'air con
et puis tu y vas prendre la marionnette
tu sais ta taille et je te fais faire et
je te fais dire ce que je veux un
tiens par exemple je t'aime aussi dit je
t'aime
je t'aime je te déteste
allez je te déteste je ne suis qu'une
marionnette sans cervelle je ne suis
qu'une marionnette chaussures que je
n'existe pas rec
c'est moi du centre sur le temps pouvait
aller d'accord je n'ai recond allez tu
vas prendre la marionnette la cie
tronche des machines hagelstein dépêche
toi ok si les palois les raids
oui mais il faut la manipuler aussi un
comme machin tu lui mets la main dans la
tête la citic
c'est le seul moyen ça y est je trouve
pas les trouve des pêches travel tu
saignes en vain allez construire il
détaillé il est tout petit il faut lui
parler avec beaucoup de douceur un ok
d'accord en cu chi le le le gros chien
chien c'est un gentil pourquoi ça dans
le sang c'est un magnet via une énigme
qu'il joue qu'il est gentil abrutis
soyez chi ventriloque mêlant d'initiés
dont la première fois la télévision
je vais faire chanter nos marionnettes
j'en prends mes gens très un jacques
chirac
dormez vous dormez vous que qu'est-ce
que c'est la suite j'ai pas j'ai
retrouvé ma relate en 100 minutes
machine tu connais non non c'est moi qui
viens de me souvenir et chez moi 20
triac un nom et celui qui chante taille
et tout le monde sait bien que je vous
ai parlé tous les deux un chef on dit
chez kill cause ici c'est moi ta taille
et mais non mais non mais non mais non
mais non mais non mais non mais non